after phalau's betrayal subsequent
manhunt and then the revelation of her
working undercover behind enemy lines
there have been a number of encrypted
comms that have been discovered
called insurance policy they provide
fragmented pieces of intel about what
she has managed to uncover and a lot of
it seems to be pointed towards an
italian circle of calvin mcmanus and
something called the hunter program
[Music]
what can i do for you now shafer i'm
just wondering where we got that support
from that's need to know shaffer and
frankly you don't need to know i'm not
comfortable with how things went down
with dusk
she was a patriot she was a rogue and a
thorn in your sight that cal helped us
remove cal isn't calvin mcmanus is he
how do you know that name shaver the
secretary of homeland security isn't
exactly a secret agent natalia miss
sokolova i'm sorry you're right miss
sokolova
i don't know what kind of operation cal
is running but
i'm not comfortable with this kind of
support noted
schaefer i know this has been difficult
but you have a habit of losing sight of
the bigger picture and remembering your
role in this organization
you could learn a lot from the people
you are working with
here we have schaefer confronting
natalya circle over
though he asks her if cal is calvin
mcmanus the secretary of homeland
security faye has already told him this
i think he just wanted to hear it from
her
at this point schaefer not only has one
foot out the door but he's also working
with feylau towards one of her major
planners to expose the true enemy and
their intentions
but natalia is a smart lady she is more
than likely to be aware of where
schaefer's head is at especially given
their last few conversations
which is why it isn't completely
surprising to see what comes for
schaefer next
thank you for cleaning house no problem
you were right to ask for support and as
much as they were your problem as former
division agents they were my
responsibility i appreciate you saying
that and being accountable
i was worried you were going to say i
owed you a favor not a favor a
replacement
thanks to schaefer's little sideshow at
coney island last night i'm down a man
this unit is hard to find suitable
replacements given the current state of
things you want to steal from my talent
pool
not steel just borrow from time to time
as the need arises
you already have a few of my operatives
in your organization
they just haven't made themselves
visible to you impressive
mind telling me which one of your wolves
is in black tusk uniform all in good
time
for now i'd like you to submit a short
list of potential replacements my
brother felix sulkalov
bridget douglas
dustin xavier
alicia coswald and he might be a little
young but
jack bonnie
let's start with bonnie
by cleaning house they're obviously
referring to the hunter that mcmanus
lent out to natalya to deal with the
troublesome rogue agents that schaefer
had spoken to her about previously
interestingly mcmanus was happy to do it
considering these agents as his
responsibility
but we need to remember that we took
down that particular hunter and now
mcmanus wants him replaced
this unit as mcmanus refers the hunters
obviously isn't all that large
while natalya expresses concern around
losing some of her talent mcmanus
mentions that there are already hunters
secretly within the black tusk ranks
it looks like engagements with the black
tusk going forward will see us facing
more of a mix between the btsu and the
hunters like at the end of countdown
this conversation finishes with natalya
listing off a number of potential
candidates for the hunter program
felix kestrel circle of bridget viper
douglas dustin mcmanus xavier alicia
cersei coswalt and jack bonnie
all of these individuals were rogue
agents who had sided with the black tusk
all apart from jack bonnie
so while they may have been better
trained to work with the shd gear and
had more experience
mcmanus obviously has no intentions of
working with former agents
you get to new york all right i'm in
would have been easier with shade or
dusk but we know why they were
unavailable be careful with this guy
i've set up far away from him if he gets
near me we can confirm that i'm his
target
this is wrong we've worked all the
angles this is the only way to be sure i
don't like using you as bait it's fine
it'll be fun your agents have been after
me for months that'll make him feel good
to take me alive yeah i just hope they
show a little restraint
they have a tendency to go for head
shots hey that's why i wear this
adorable helmet
good luck safer won't need it
they'll face this hunter and know
something isn't right council will order
the agents to apprehend you for
questioning and you can brief her on
mcmanus and sokolova we can't let them
finish their project and i'll only tell
kelso she's the only one we can be sure
isn't rogue
i trust her with my life
she's the best agent i've ever met she's
smart and capable and even if she likes
to blow things up
she will be too curious to let you die i
hope you're right
good luck with chicken hawk
i guess it's time to get arrested just
don't blow my cover when they bring you
in what if they come after you next
don't blow my cover
so i would say that this was the last
time they spoke to each other and prior
to the previous comms we just went
through schaefer has just arrived in new
york after the rest of his lieutenants
have been taken down presumably in
preparation for his operation on coney
island
from this we can confirm that it was a
part of faye's plan
he was always meant to be captured and
more importantly to show them this
hunter
obviously all of these conversations
with natalya had eventually led him to
being hunted down too like the rest of
his rogue agents
but they were playing it pretty hopeful
with this plan as there hasn't been too
many others that we've taken alive
because his next step was to inform
kelso of more information around natalia
and mcmanus
even kelso hasn't exactly been known to
hold back
so it was a pretty risky game to play
but i guess that's why these comms are
called insurance policy
faye left these behind just in case
schaefer ended up being killed
lucky thing too as we find out in the
final cut scene he's been in a coma for
weeks now
we need to talk
bro so you're talking to me again you
buddies in new york too busy to take
your call i finished decrypting lao's
insurance policy did you tell you why
she did it
there's no way she can justify joining
black tusk and assassinating the
president
when did everything get so complicated
the minute one [ __ ] decided his
christmas present to the world was a
global pandemic
[ __ ] amherst
we've contained that threat but there's
a bigger one on the horizon i know
whatever the true sons have been
fighting what faye was helping them
fight what she was trying to warn us
about
she figured out what was really going on
and she tried to warn us
but we didn't get the message
she tried to give us a clue back at
coney island and an ally
where's schaefer
same place he always is what's his
status
stable but in a coma been like this for
weeks and we're just tube feeding our
enemy
he's not our enemy
not anymore
manny
he's the key
she left us a key and if we want to stop
what's coming
we need to wake him up
so
[Music]
[Music]
so schaefer is the key
here's the information that the division
need in order to fully understand what
natalia and mcmanus are up to
but like i said before could this
information not have been included with
the rest of these fail outcomes
maybe she didn't get around to it or
we're going to receive them later
it just seems odd that she would leave
us half the story as part of a
contingency plan with the comms but
leave the rest to sit with schaefer
isn't it interesting that after all this
time we finally see manny again it
really feels like it's been ages
it also seems very sus that he's been
brought back for this but perhaps this
is because he's the last character we
know of left in the white house
he's obviously been looking after the
place and that includes the overseeing
of schaefer who remains unconscious
perhaps he'll have a larger part to play
in the coming seasons
so what do we now know from these
insurance policy comms
schaefer and fey were working together
baden was meant to be captured on coney
island
mcmanus the secretary of homeland
security is working with natalya and
appears to be in control
he also has a unit of super elite
soldiers called the hunters
but other than that we don't really know
what they're up to
all of the focus seems to be on the
hunter program but this alone can't be
what they're so concerned about there
must be something more
sure they're tough specialized units who
seem to be quite adept at taking out
division agents but they must have a
greater cause that they've been put in
place for
they're really just a small group
in the greater scheme of things with the
rebuilding of the country and
establishing a new world order what is
their purpose
or maybe that's the whole point they're
there to remove the division leaving the
much larger force of black task to take
control of the country
but if this is true
the division already don't seem like
they're in much of a position to be able
to stop the black task
their numbers are low and they are
heavily divided
much like general anderson said
lone wolves
they're currently unequipped to be able
to take on a well-coordinated nationwide
attack from a considerably larger force
going back to the same old question i've
been asking for years
is this what kino had seen coming
was he trying to warn us of mcmanus this
whole time
this was just a quick recap or overview
of the comms we've received at the end
of the manhunt real life has been
throwing some interesting things my way
as of lately so this took a little
longer than i would like to get out
i'm already planning on pulling this
apart and digging a little deeper but i
needed a starting point
another piece that i realized i really
need to put together is some sort of
character slash faction mind map that
shows the crossover between each over
the years
this season has added so much and
referenced a lot of events from earlier
that i think we could all use some sort
of law quick reference chart or guide
as always thank you very much for your
support i hope you've enjoyed the video
and i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]